what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 17th of may
the joint is brought to you by blue
blocks
i've already told you about the blue
blocks amazing sleep mask
i'll tell you what ever since i've been
wearing my mask i've been averaging at
least an extra 45 to an hour a night a
good [__] solid sleep
and now i'm here to tell you about their
light filtering glasses
they're [__] tremendous you get any
style
color or size plus if you go to the
website the blueblocks
website dot com they have a virtual try
on which i think is [__] tremendous
listen
when i go with a sponsor i look at their
website and if their website is tip top
magoo
that makes me lean towards them a lot
more and blueblox has an amazing
website they also like i said to you
they're introducing
to you right now sleep plus the red
lenses for true blue and green light
blocking
use after sundown if you have trouble
sleeping or get anxious at night
these are for you then we got you clear
blue light lens
filter blue light during the day if you
spend all day in front of the computer
this is for you cut down on headaches
and i strain and finally
you got the summer glow you got the
yellow lenses
color therapy for the winter blues
clinically proven
to lift your mood plus you get all the
benefits of blue blocking
they sent me two pair of glasses one for
the computer
and one for at night to watch tv and to
reduce it and i'll tell you what
i've been wearing them for the last 10
days and i've seen
my headaches have gone down guys i'm
always on that goddamn computer
you need some glasses so right now go to
blueblocks.com
blue blocks is a science-based company
that lenses are made under
laboratory conditions you got a
prescription
no problem they'll make it to your
specifications now that's what i'm
talking about
these are high quality lenses not mass
produced
and they come in a ton of styles so go
to that website
and take a look they're high quality
lenses from glasses to sleep masks
they've got everything you might need
for light therapy and guess what
that customer service is out of this
world
go with them today so right now i'm
telling you support blue blocks
because they support the show get 20
percent off with code joey
at blueblocks.com joey
right now that's blueblox.com joey for
20 off blueblocks.com
joey for 20 off go with blue blocks
you're gonna be very impressed the joint
is also brought to you by
cbd lion listen i'm sick and tired of
telling you
about how good cbd lion is this week i
switched it up again
i went back to that great cbd gummies
with the melatonin in it and i got to
tell you something
i've been sleeping like a baby i rub the
cream on my knee
i when i take a bath i use the bath ball
cbd lion has hemp flower they have hemp
joints they got the roll-on they i mean
listen they got
chocolate that is tremendous a dark
chocolate and a milk chocolate
if you need cbd cbd line or get it into
your system right now
go to cbd line and read up on the third
party lab results
go to cbd line right now press and join
or church and get 20 off your order
right now
at cbd lion let's get this party started
where's this [__] lighter at
boom candles lit [__]
let's get this show on the road
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 17th of may
we are [__] three-quarters there and
we're a month out of [__] wearing
masks
and putting up a [__] anymore it's
over we're out of it
uh i don't know what the only thing can
happen maybe some indian guy bites you
in the neck
but besides that we're [__] done you
know what i'm saying it's all over but
the shouting
uh was a great week last week i had a
great time uh
the nfts went over great thank you very
much on patreon
mike wheat whistle great uh friday night
we had a softball game
the families went out after that for
[__] a big dinner you know
pizza and wings and [__] and then
saturday we had a big [__] game down
in freehold tremendous and
sunday parties i mean i was looking at
my schedule before not my schedule
i went to the kitchen and i was looking
at their schedule
which i'm part of you know what i'm
saying and it's really weird how
you gotta see the month of may like it
runs straight
to [__] memorial day we don't stop
and then memorial day weekend
there ain't no beach like everybody's
like oh tomorrow day weekend we're going
to the show we got so much [__]
just in the neighborhood there's a day
we have we can't even go to
the one kid's party i gotta go to a
kid's party and my wife has to go to a
party
and then we're gonna switch mercy around
that's how busy
we are here that's how [__] different
life is from [__] california here i
mean there's a children's state
this is a [__] child state this is
all i'm involved in i i
there's some days i'm like what the [__]
is going on in my life and there's some
days i'm like this is
what i'm supposed to be doing
when i was out on the road i wasn't
dealing with this stuff i didn't really
know what was going on and i'm really
sorry
and this is why now i'm all [__] in
that this has happened you know so i'm
really i'm really happy that uh
we're here we did some great things this
weekend she's [__] coming along
just fine and yours truly looking better
than ever
trying two weeks no reefer [__]
sunday anniversary
i mean you know and again you know those
[__] that go to rehab
and they come out and they try to make
you feel bad like
my life's all different now i feel so
much energy
i'm not eating pasta anymore rice
clayton
it's not about that it's not about that
at all
it's just about i would love to [__]
you guys and tell you that i ran up a
mountain clay
without wheezing and [__] like that but
no it's the same
i feel good i'm just doing it just to
give it a break so
i can get high like you normal
[__]
because i'm not normal this is not
normal this [__] is not normality this
[__] i was doing
but anyway what i want to talk to you
about this monday morning is what
happened last week
and what we do is comics and what
people expect from you as a comic and
what you can say
as a comic anymore when i got into this
i dove into this 150
for the first [__] six months of
comedy
yes i was a [__] and i didn't get on
stage and i worked as a doorman
i was watching i was watching
i was reading there was no internet
it wasn't like there was an internet and
i could [__] go on there and find out
about
stand up or anything i would just read
i would read anything i thought stand up
once a month
a [__] newspaper came out about
stand-up
out of san francisco john fox i forget
what the newspaper was it really doesn't
matter but that's the only
way you had to know what was going on
or unless you went to a comedy club
there was really no internet
so my first introduction to comedy was
richard pryor
what comes out of that man's mouth what
came out of his mouth that you didn't
hear before
everything everything came out of his
[__] mouth
and then my second introduction was
george carlin who i didn't like as much
as richard pryor i was more of a richard
pryor type of guy
and then once i got into comedy more and
more and more like i like david brenner
and i remember freddie prince
and i remember those guys they weren't
my all-time favorites
but once kennyson came and dice came and
[__]
you know uh bill hicks came along
i started studying them i really
studied them i bought i didn't buy i
rented because i didn't have the money
to buy
59 for a video is a lot of money in
those days
i'd rather pay i'd rather spend 300 on
renting it
than just buy it outright for 59 [__]
dollars like a normal person
but i rented it every [__] other day
and they ended up paying like 2 000
instead of 49 the point is i looked at
everything
hand mannerisms i got a notebook and i
looked at hand mannerisms the way they
stand
i made notes for who touches the mic who
doesn't touch the mic
why they don't touch the mic is there a
reason are they animated with their
hands when they're explaining to you
who goes back and forth i i studied all
that
you know i studied all that and then
when i was on the road
i would go to libraries to kill time
these are things that people don't know
about me
if i had a night in idaho city what the
[__] is there to do when i the whole
city with a studio 50 [__] four
there ain't nothing to [__] do in the
daytime so i would just go to a library
and ask them about biographies and stuff
like that
and i started reading about an
interesting guy named lenny bruce
i told you guys years ago rogan has put
it up on his podcast
the book to read is ladies and gentlemen
lenny bruce
and how to talk dirty and influence
people and
how to make friends i read all those
books abby hoffman steal this book
you're dealing with the wrong [__]
guy here i've read all those [__]
books
when i moved to bold i was into all that
hippy [__] you know abby hoffman and all
that stuff that's part of the [__]
game
but when i started reading about
i can't remember what lenny bruce was
when my eyes really opened up
to what he had gone through i don't know
if you guys have any idea who lenny
bruce is
but lenny bruce was a comic i think from
the 60s 50s
70s whatever the [__] and his big thing
was he was blue
and he kept getting in trouble see the
only places you could perform
in those days as a stand-up comic were
at strip clubs
or burlesque shows like when i went to
tennessee
to visit my in-laws a couple years ago
there's a comedy club in jackson that is
[__] tremendous it's just a little
cave
but it used to be a burlesque place so
it couldn't be in nashville because you
know what i'm saying they would [__]
bust you
so they made it like 45 minutes 30
minutes i don't know how far jackson is
outside of nashville don't
what am i [__] map quest i don't know
but i know that
it's like a half hour or something it's
outside of city limits
do you know what i'm saying it was like
outside so it was like burlesque that
owner was telling me that it was a
blessed place
and that lenny bruce had performed there
i mean that this is all
you know so there was no there was no
comedy clubs
the first comedy club was supposedly a
funny bone out of pittsburgh that was
i don't know how true it is if you guys
want to research it and get back to me
on it get back to me
but that's the word on the street it was
a guy in syracuse named bruno sharipa
and there was a guy in pittsburgh there
were brothers and supposedly they opened
up the first
i don't know how real this is you guys
could fact check me i'm just telling you
what the [__] i heard
i didn't have time to [__] read up on
it but this is
what i read about all those years i read
about lenny bruce and what he had gotten
through
what he had gone through for us okay
like for other comics to come
like he was getting arrested you know
whatever and then you got jim morrison
and now we're talking about music and he
was doing something completely different
he took his dick out in miami
and all this [__] and he said [__] on
stage he was talking stuff
on stage but those two guys let's focus
on what those two guys did
it's called artistic freedom for people
who don't know it
okay it's called artistic freedom
once you hit that stage there's a thing
that's called
artistic freedom now don't get me wrong
what comes out of your mouth should be
funny
when you have artistic [__] freedom i
mean we all [__]
uh agree on that okay
number two it's not what you say
it's how you say remember these words
for the rest of your [__] life
i could tell you hey [__] you or hey
[__] you they sounded completely
different
and both of them had completely
different meanings to them
that same [__] you had two different
meanings to it
so always remember that when you go on
stage
you know as comics we think of every
[__] bombing
i could tell you every bomb alert you
know i can't tell you what i had for
breakfast this morning
but i could tell you through the years
the bomb alerts i had
i could tell you through the years the
bad
jokes i said and they fell through
they fell down i remember through the
years when i tried to be
cute and be edgy
that i would fall on my face because
people see right through that
people see right through that you guys
are smarter than that as an audience
that's why i said to you a couple weeks
ago that i respect the audience
as a comic i have always respected the
audience
i don't know if you guys know what the
wall is about the album the wall
and i don't like this but i'm gonna tell
you anyway the album the wall was about
pink floyd one of my favorite bands
but it was roger waters
mr [__] personality himself who got
agitated
and somebody asked him how the audience
was or something again don't quote me on
this
and he said these shows would be great
if i could build a wall between myself
and the audience that was the worst
[__] thing i've ever heard come out
of somebody's [__]
mouth yeah i still listen to pink floyd
and i love pink floyd as a whole
but i'm not into roger waters because of
those words
because of his arrogance because of
him breaking up a band because of his
[__] arrogance but
that's not what this podcast is about
this podcast is about the respect for
the audience
i have respect for you guys what does
that mean that
i know comics personally who don't give
a [__] about the audience
and in the back of my mind i have to
tell myself that
to win to [__]
you know kick some [__] ass but in
reality i
very much care about my audience i care
that you [__]
gee i cared that you [__]
got a babysitter i care that you paid 80
dollars for [__] a dinner
i cared that you took the time out to
buy tickets when i tweeted
so when i go up there i gotta give you
the highest
level of [__] respect that there is
as a comic
okay always remember that that this is
in the back of my mind
now when you pay the 25 bucks to see me
do
comedy there's no meet and greets
involved i'm not worried about the
[__] meet and greet i'm not worried
about anything
i'm worried about the performance i'm
about to give you
when i go up on stage you know there's a
joke i was working on before i took a
break
that people in jersey when we were kids
we didn't go out to play
we went out to die we didn't go out to
play
look at all these [__] things they're
talking about class action park all that
[__]
when i was a kid we went out to die we
didn't go out to play we jumped off
trees we made milk crates
we put boards up we went off [__]
motorcycles and if you fell and broke
your neck you fell and broke your
[__] neck nobody was crying nobody
was [__] complaining
nobody was putting the blame on
everybody timmy put the brick wrong
no who gives a [__] you weren't supposed
to be building a [__] ramp and riding
your motorcycle off like kz
175 the thing's gonna [__] break but
my point is
which i don't know what it is anymore
i've gone off on a [__] tangent is
that [__]
you know i respect the audience that's
my number one
[__] priority all time whether
they're three years
or two thousand of you i have a certain
respect for the audience
so i remember every bomb
every bad joke every stupid racist joke
that i said
because hey i'm normal i'm i'm like
anybody else i'm
not [__] racist but i have said
racist things on stage to get a laugh
the audience knows i'm not racist that's
why they laughed
because it comes back to not what you
say
it's how you say it i'll give you a
[__] particular story about me
that destroyed my insides i really liked
this joke
and i really wanted it to work but i
didn't know
how else to make it work and it's about
tom brady
i'm a big fan of tom brady i like tom
brady
there's a problem i have with tom brady
not really a problem
it's not a problem i don't want anybody
to say tom joey's got a problem with tom
brady no
the only the only burp i have with tom
brady that i think
is funny to be honest with you is that
he dumped
his pregnant wife to
go with a brazilian chick with a
tremendous ass now
i'm a catholic don't get me wrong so is
tom brady you know what i'm saying he's
as catholic as can be
but to dump a pregnant woman is
something
i have never even thought about in my
life it's like me being 15
and that girl telling me that her mother
died that you know when she was [__]
panicking i'm like
what can you do what did you do for your
mother to [__] die what can you do in
a prior life
that your mother [__] died what can
you possibly [__] do i'd never talk
to that girl again
then my mother died and i felt [__]
bad because what did i do in a prior
[__] life
but what the [__] we talk i don't even
know
so what the [__] did you do in a prior
life
to deserve having no [__] mother you
understand me i mean i
i don't understand this so when it was
first presented to me my head almost
[__] blew up
that's the same way i did when [__]
tom brady
dumped that catholic girl so i wanted to
write a joke about it i'm like what the
[__] can i say about tom brady for doing
this
and i was up in buffalo one night look i
even remember the city
okay i remember everything don't [__]
tell me i was in buffalo had to be about
2016. i was opening up for rogan
and i was talking to rogan about tom
brady
i go [__] brady that [__] and
then he dumped his [__] pregnancy
and i go you know the crazy thing about
that [__] dumping a pregnant [__] that
[__] that
[__] spanish people and black people
do that's all i said
that's all i said that and i even claim
spanish people
so it's not really racist here i even
claim spanish
that's the kind of [__] spanish people
and black people do and rogan said say
it up on stage
dog when i set it up on stage it died a
slow death
and guess what i never said it again i
understood that's a racist [__] joke
even if you
even if you throw a spanish people under
the bus first which
you do as a wordsmith you put the
spanish first so people won't get the
initial shock
of the black i didn't say anything else
i just said black
and spanish it didn't [__] work and i
got off stage and i'm like
that's not at this point in my life you
know when if i would if it was 2008
and i was still desperado still young
and comedy
yeah i would have done that [__] joke
and kept working on it and tried to be
cute with it but at that point in 2016 i
already had a daughter
i had things going on i'm gonna tell
that joke
for what what's it gonna do for me i
liked it trust me i like the [__]
joke that's the problem i
i enjoyed i thought there was something
funny there but the audience didn't
think it was funny you know
i took it and i moved on with it i
thought about it i
wrote it out and i read it and it seemed
racist to me
you know guys on stage i've said a
thousand things and nothing
you can't say to me afterward when i get
off hey joey that wasn't a good joke you
can't
because i say with a smile on my face
which is very important and that
the tone in your voice is very important
how you say it
dog i used to have to follow ali wong at
the store
do you have any idea what that's like
people no you don't
there was two people at the store three
people let's say three people at the
store
that when i had a follow i had to kick
it into overdrive
number one bill burr i mean he's the
[__] greatest
you when you follow bill burr you better
bring up your a's and d's
whatever the [__] you better take all
your vitamins magnesium
[__] everything chris dalia you
better [__] come with some energy
with crystalline
and allie wong was possibly the toughest
because she's a woman
okay when people go to a stand-up show
all they see is dick constantly
take your girlfriends to a stand-up show
there's three sets of [__] dick
that's what she's gonna see is three
male comics
85 percent of the times every once in a
while they might put a woman in there
you know there's a woman comic on the
schedule but now
i think i'm exaggerating i say 70 of the
times it's three dicks
so a woman has to put up with an hour
and a half
of listening to a male's [__]
perspective
put a woman in the middle now the women
will have a great time that's why i
always use kate quigley
to open for me a chelsea skidmore a
carmen morales i like those women in
front of me because
it gives the audience and gives the
women in the show
something they're not going to go there
and get stuck with [__] fat man joey
beers for 40 minutes talking about
eating your ass and
spitting pubic hairs in your eyes and
all that [__] that could only take so
much of that so you got to put a woman
in there
now let me tell you something if that
woman is funny
like kate was like carmen morales was
like chelsea skidmore was you better
watch them
i see a lot of male comics that a woman
goes up in front of them and they're
like
ah no problem i'll just pay attention
i'll just play pay playstation five
whatever the [__] comics do
when a woman goes up before me guys i
watch that woman
i watch her like she was naked
i watch her like she was [__] naked
because women are deadly up on stage if
they get a cyclone going
you're dead and i've seen it before
i've seen beaumont bacon blow people off
the [__] stage
years ago there was a comic there was a
[__]
dud comic i remember no name stood
he's a [__] dud this guy dudley and i
remember one time i was doing shows in
san diego
and he was working la jolla
and i stopped in la jolla to say hello
to see how the show was going
i wasn't looking for a guest at nothing
i just stopped in
i knew him i knew beaumont bacon
and i just wanted to say hello and he
came out first and was talking to me and
he goes
yeah i got these two shows [__]
beaumont things she's got a headline
you know and i looked at him and i sat
and listened for like 10 minutes
and i tried to let his ego off
as lightly as i can i said dog
this is joey diaz is thinking i said why
don't you
let her headline
the first show and you headlined the
second show
i'm giving him an out so he wouldn't
need a bag of dicks up on stage
because i knew beaumont bacon was gonna
[__] those people up
and la joya is always couples
you get to learn these little nuances as
you do
comedy some clubs you go to and it's 60
40. it's male 1 60 40
females la jolla on saturday is a date
club
so if there's 200 people in there
there's 100 women in there
are you with me here so far so when i
went in there
i just went to talk to him to say hello
he's telling me how he's the best comic
in the world
that he can follow anybody and i'm
trying to let him off the ledge and be
smart and go
because even if even if it was me
even if it was joey diaz i would have
let bulma and bacon open up the first
show
even though i knew i could follow her i
would have let her open up the second
show
so she wouldn't [__] destroy me the
second show because the second show
they're a little drunker and the early
show of parents and old people
and people don't want to hear bad words
and [__] like that
so you go to the early show 10 30 shows
i'm the king of 10 30 shows that's when
guys like me
go on stage and i could go up there and
talk about eating [__] and
spitting out hemorrhoids houston
whatever the [__] i talk about
you know i'm just talking here i'm just
talking here i mean
so what you do is that's the psychology
that i'll go up for the second show and
rip them apart well when i pulled him
aside like a man
and as a friend i said to him yo let her
open up the second show
and you closed the second show and he's
like
not a million years [__] her i'm gonna
she's
i'm gonna follow her with no problem so
guess what i did
against my best wishes i got a bottle of
water and i said [__] it
i'm gonna miss the coke dealer at 10 30
but i'm gonna get more entertainment
from watching him die a slow death
i just knew it i just [__] knew it it
doesn't take a genius
and if you don't know it as a comic
remember last week i was talking to you
about checking yourself
this is part of checking yourself it's
not that you're being a coward
it's nothing like that in comedy is that
you're trying to stack the odds in your
favor
that's all i'm trying to do you want to
stack the odds in your favor as a comic
as a human being as a car salesman as a
guitar player
you always want to you follow me
so it's like if you think aerosmith
comes out with dream on
when they open up where would they go
where the [__] would they go they came
out with dream on dream on
well what we're going to dream on to
next what are we going on tonight and
i'm exaggerating harold schmidt's got a
great catalog
but what i'm trying to say to you is you
don't come out with your with your best
[__] material so
i'm sitting there that night and i'm and
i just sat there listening and no
look for years i always said i could
make it home
from la jolla to l.a in an hour 25.
people like you're lying you're lying
when you're addicted to coke
you're making an hour 25. i could make i
could i would do 100 from la jolla
to the immigration center i would slow
down till 90.
and then once i went through and they
asked you do you have any oranges or
apples
i would say no i don't have any oranges
or apples and they would say go on
through
and i would do a hundred to irvine and
once i got to irvine i would slow it
down to like 90 and once i saw 18 miles
out of la
it went back up to 100 and i would get
to my [__] drug dealer's house in
time on this particular night
i said [__] it i was going to meet the
drug deal like a 10 i called them back i
said i'll be up at 11 30. i got to watch
this massacre
he goes what are you talking about i'll
tell you when i get there i sat there
and i watched this [__] beaumont
bacon
wipe up the floor with this kid
wipe up the floor with this kid and then
i did what a good comic would do like i
tell mikey
don't talk watch
keep your eye on that comic i wanted to
see how he would react when he came off
the stage
that's the money right there so when he
came out i went up to him bro i gotta go
great set you know i knew he ate a bag
of dicks
i knew he you could see it on his face
he was flustered
he didn't know what to do and he came up
to me i shook his hand
and i didn't say a word and he looked at
me and he goes
i think you're right maybe i'll let
beaumont close the second shot
i tried to tell you i tried to save you
fight i didn't say that to him
i thought about that in the car because
i'm not in business to [__] squash
somebody's dreams
i was just trying to work with him
from the right spot here just explain to
him listen bro
just sometimes it's a comic sometimes
it's a human being sometimes as anything
you gotta see things for what the [__]
they are
so with all that said like
when you do dirty material or whatever i
mean
i love tony i have nothing against tony
this is gonna blow over this will be
gone in six months
thank god ari released the video footage
of what happened before and what after
it doesn't sting that much
it doesn't hurt that much it was you
could just write it off to
comedy cockiness you know i've had it
we've all gone through it
and that's it but it's not enough to
cancel somebody i mean
uh i'm not gonna lie to you i have a
problem
with people putting phones and sacks
i would never in my life do that to you
people when you come to one of my shows
i feel that you have children i feel
that you have grandparents i feel that
you have families
what if somebody needs you what if
somebody i think you actually put the
phone
in a pouch and if you want to make a
call or whatever you i don't know the
rules
to everything with the phone and the
pouch i know dave chappelle does a lot
a lot of other comics are starting to do
it if i go on the road now
i'm going to start to do it because
i don't need somebody taking a [__]
phone out when i'm doing a joke because
listen
it's like did you ever see uh
a couple of years ago they show you how
they take
reviews and change them
so a movie comes out let's say me and
mike are movie reviewers
and we write
the review of the movie and we write two
sentences
the movie took us for a tremendous ride
but it was boring as [__]
what the movie people do is they erase
the boring as [__]
and all you see is this was a hell of a
thrill ride
do you follow them saying to you now so
they take that back end off
and all you see is this film was a great
ride
you're not gonna see this film was
boring as [__]
i wanted to shoot myself by the end
you're not gonna read that
they eliminate that thing that's why
when ari put that up
a couple of my friends watched it and
they all had the same result they're
like it doesn't seem
like and don't get me wrong you know uh
the word that was used is offensive have
i used it
i've used it you know uh
maybe on stage maybe in daily life or
whatever as a joke
but there's no hatred here you know i
think for tony
it was i think if he would have gone up
and said
the filthy puerto rican i don't think it
would have been as bad
because of everything that's going on
with asian hate
so i'm not mad at tony i just think it
was a bad night
and i wish people you know just get over
this
um you know i'm very sorry
i'll apologize for tony to the asian
community
i don't want you to think i'm bringing
light to this in any way
what i'm trying to do is explain what
happens when a comic
goes on stage and
what you could take from that and how
you know it's a [__] comedy show
you know we have the freedom of speech
in this country
that's what makes this country special i
know when you go
to other [__] countries and [__] like
that there's things you can't talk about
on stage i think hari told me like when
he went to china and somewhere else
they limit your stuff
[Music]
this is the united states of [__]
america
you could say whatever they want let me
tell you something else
as a comic if you come up to me
and tell me not to say something i'm
gonna go up there and say it
i'm gonna go up there and say it that's
where the respect factor comes from
that's where i gain respect as a human
being
for myself and from my fellow comedians
i'm not talking about going up there and
saying again i'll give an example
one of my favorite all-time comics bill
hicks
he was performing in denver and kevin
fitzgerald
dr kevin fitzgerald the vet
was on was doing comedy i don't know if
you guys know kevin fitzgerald from
the animal channel animal planet he had
a show on there where he saved cats and
[__]
kevin fitzgerald i spoke about him on
the church is one of the most
interesting men in the world i think
rogan had him on the podcast
he went to vietnam he was a [__]
bodyguard for the [__] stones
he was a bodyguard for [__] you know
just bands and [__]
uh got the gi bill put himself to
[__] college and became a [__] vet
and then while he was a vet he did
[__] comedy but let me tell you
something about
kevin fitzgerald he's a mild-mannered
dude he's got white hair
he's a gentleman kevin fitzgerald will
light your [__] ass up
and if you ever watch go look him up on
youtube right now
he's working on a cat or he's saving a
dog's ear or something like that
and you see the compassion of god don't
get confused with kevin fitzgerald
ken fitzgerald take an eye to go and
they'll send it back to you in the
[__] mail with
on fire kevin fitzgerald is no joke bro
one night kev fitzgerald's at the
[__] comedy works in denver
and he's opening up for bill hicks and
he said that joke about uh
he took you know he took uh there used
to be a show on
the commercial this is your mind this is
your brain
this is your brain on drugs and he did
so i don't remember the joke
so i'm not gonna give it any justice or
by repeating it
kevin went up there and said the joke
when he got off he said that
bill hicks's bodyguard walked over to
him
and told him not to do the joke again
that mr hicks talks about marijuana in
his and his routine
so kevin fitzgerald said i got an option
i got to make a decision here
this is bill hicks the greatest comic of
all [__] time one of the top [__]
three in my [__] book
and he just gave you a direct order
to not say a [__] joke i mean what do
you do
what do you think kevin fitzgerald did
he went back yep then did the joke
and he he he did the joke to be honest
with you
from kevin's mouth kevin told me that he
did the joke
to [__] incite the [__] security
guy because he wanted to secure
hicks a security guy to say something to
him he was gonna knock him the [__] out
because he remembered the guy from the
old days when the guy would work
consciously do really mean things to
kids
so kevin went up there to do the joke so
the guy would say something to him
so kevin could rip his [__] ear off
guess what happened
kevin got off the stage he did the joke
bill hicks walked up to him and said
that's what a real comic does you just
became my [__] opener
you're traveling with me from now on do
you understand what i'm trying to say to
you
you all watched [__] uh
fresh out of compton whatever the [__]
the name of the movie straight out of
compton the fresh out of compton
something out of compton yeah fresh
prince out of compton
you all watch straight out of compton uh
there's a part where they go to detroit
and the cops give them a [__] air
beat and again
you know i have nothing but appreciation
and love for the [__] men in blue
blue lives matter in my [__] world i
dig the cops
i was the detective today uh all weekend
they spent time with the detective at my
daughter's softball game his son
plays so they come to the [__] games
we go to their game so we went out to
dinner i got nothing against cops
well we talking about blue lives matter
whatever the [__]
uh and i'm not even smoking pockets you
imagine if i was [__] smoking pot
i wouldn't remember [__] [__] but in
straight out of compton the cops give
them a [__] airbeat before they get
on stage
and they're like listen when you get up
there don't if you say [__] the police
we're gonna [__]
oh yeah they're gonna stop the show did
they [__] go up there and listen
no because his artist would not gonna
listen
listen that's what being an artist is
if not we'd get in line and do what
everybody else did
we'd get in line and do what everybody
else did so
but still that still doesn't justify
what happened last week on stage but
what i'm trying to say to you people is
don't put too much of your mind into it
because it's not even [__] worth it
it's just a joke and i'm sure tony's
apologetic to the kid
who he said it to and he's apologetic to
the asian community it's a [__] joke
guys
you know we're living in a time right
now where
it's rough people are having a rough
[__] time
but if you're gonna give people
that are trying to bring you
entertainment a rough time for making a
mistake
it's not gonna work out somewhere it's
not gonna work out somewhere this could
this could have been with a band this
could have been with a magician
this could happen with anybody anybody
could have said something bad you know
what i'm saying
i know i go on stage sometimes and like
i said i remember
everything bad that i've said in my
[__] 30-year career
i can tell you the cities i said i'm at
i could tell you how i felt
afterward and i could tell you if i'm
going to do that joke again or not
and i used one particular joke for you
people and i did say it on stage
and how somebody didn't tape me and put
it on youtube and try to [__] hang me
at the cross
is beyond them and it's because it's not
what you say
it's how you say it this is the comedy
business
i'm gonna say a lot of [__] that you
people don't agree with
but i'm not a [__] physical therapist
i'm not a psycho
whatever i didn't go to yale you know
i'm not tom morello i'm not a double
major and whatever
so i keep it to the world that i know
and it's stand-up comedy
and humanity and how to treat people and
how to [__] be with people
i don't try to be something that i'm
[__] not here
but you can't get mad at everybody's
[__] stupid [__]
you have to pick your battles you know
uh am i mad at tony not at all
as a brother as another comic as another
i'm not disappointed in the audience i'm
not disappointed in anybody
it was just a bad night guys that's it
that's where it [__] ends now on the
brighter side
let's not talk about no more jokes or
whatever the [__] this week
i released an nft on patreon i
listen guys like i said
there's been so much doom and gloom in
the last 14 [__] months
that if i could light myself on fire for
you people to entertain you and there
wouldn't be no
[__] [__] up skin and i had to come
out here with my [__] up eyeballs
and say i had a good time entertaining
you people i let myself on fire i would
if you know anything about me i would do
anything
to change your mood i live
to make somebody's day to look at
somebody
whether it's give them a dollar a smile
something to get them away from whatever
the [__] is pulling them down in their
life
that's what life is all about for me
when somebody's
[__] like confused you hit them with
a stupid joke
and you bring a smile to their face and
for [__] five seconds
you took them away from their miserable
[__] whatever the [__] was going on
you know friday i had a [__] up day i
had to go to a doctor
and i had a guitar lesson with rudy
sarzo and guess what happened i went to
the [__]
doctor and then i was running late as it
was the doctor was running an hour
behind
and then [__] my insurance stuff
didn't [__] uh
go through at the doctor and i had to
call sag for 45 [__] minutes i was on
hold with sag and blah blah blah blah
blah blah
i got a little bit agitated my agitation
which
was because i was blowing i was rudy was
taking the time out of his busy day
to just work with me for 30 minutes and
i couldn't make it from freehold home
you know in time and then when i got
downstairs in the [__] car my tire
was low and
you know what and at the gas station
when i was filling up the tire
like i was like [__] this sucks i had to
text rudy
but i said in a large context
nothing happened he was running late
that was an accident my insurance
was [__] up it was a clerical accident
the tire went low it's an accident it's
it's something that happens
that does not qualify a bad day
does not qualify a bad day my cat
getting hit by a [__] car
that's a bad [__] day i love that
[__] cat any of my cats you know
mike's dog getting hit by a [__]
that's a bad day so i also want you to
think about
your bad days and you guys got to
toughen up your skin a little bit
you know i realized that the other day
i'm like this had a bad day
this is life these are things that
happen your mother dying my friends
my mike ronnie and his sisters and their
mother dying
that's a bad day that's a bad [__]
year
that's a bad year and it accelerates on
mother's day in the [__] holidays so
that's bad i'm here to change that
i i i hope that when i do this podcast
just to joke about the hemorrhoid and
you giggled
that just took you away from stuff so
for the last year
from last july all i've been trying to
do is to
get you guys out of a funkier mood
something different
you know i started this patreon you know
we help people
we give out little [__] loans we help
people nobody has to ask for nothing
around me
the first thing we did was send out
t-shirts i didn't like it
i didn't like it anybody could give you
a [__] t-shirt i tried to make it
light blue
i tried to give you a nice insignia
and then you know i said [__] it for the
next round of stuff i'll do mugs
you know i'll do mugs that's great a
coffee mug
everybody needs a coffee mug right it's
the mind of joey diaz coffee mug you
guys
i think i get them in june i'll send
them out to patreon
but then this guy contacted me with this
nft
you know the florentine uh crime family
brother bob that's all he talks to me
about his bitcoin and nfts and
and i'm watching what this nft thing is
you know uh
i think death row did some a couple
other people did some
so i said it's something [__]
different when they contacted me
they were talking about these prices and
i go no again i don't want to make them
higher than the ticket price
so i kept them at 25 [__] dollars
and i couldn't give them to you because
they came
from a certain company and like i bought
one
i would have liked to buy 10 and gave
one to mike and gave one to lee
and gave one to my daughter and gave one
to i couldn't buy
i didn't even know how to do it it went
to a different [__] wallet my wife
had to pin it and save it
thank god they sent you an email so you
have whatever the transaction
but i had to wait to the next days for
bob to come over and teach me about
wallets and all that [__] [__]
anyway the reason why i did the nft
was just as something different i didn't
see any
any other comics doing it and i wanted
to bring you like a little trading card
cops reached out about a year ago and
they want to do a trading card thing
through steve simone i thought about it
i'm like ah
i don't know if i want to send a little
[__] card to patreon
they pay me 10 bucks i'm going to send
them a [__] baseball card
i want to give you something that that
you know and when i heard about it was
investment
opportunities and [__] like that i said
[__] it what's the worst that could
happen
i charge 25 bucks trust me i don't get
the full 25 bucks
they had to set that thing up the
company takes money
and my agent takes a [__] commission
then guys it's just
i live my life through eight or nine
different little faucets and together
that's how i make my money but all those
faucets don't make you much money
alone they don't make you much money
when i put it together with eight
faucets
then i could eat a [__] nice steak
but alone you gotta go jerry what are
you doing that for
you know but that's not the point i
wanted you guys to have something
different
and i wanted you guys it's a 25
investment i know you [__]
there's one guy on patreon i can't
believe
people are broke and you're doing this
no they're not no they're not
nobody's even [__] working nobody's
even wants to go back to work all you
[__]
are getting that extra 300 600 i don't
know what you get
some states are cutting it georgia a
couple of states of color because
nobody's going to [__] work
but instead of blowing your money on
alcohol drugs
[__] weed all summer stupid [__]
get an nft for 25 [__] bucks i turned
around people were selling them for
three grand two grand
12 grand some guy sent me an email joey
i made some money i want to send you
money i go no
i don't want your money that's yours
this is for the guys that signed up in
the beginning and they paid 15
a month and they paid six months at 105
i just made them their money back to pay
joey
whether they want to sign up again with
me or not i don't give a [__] that night
listen
they did what they had to do i made them
a little money if they want to sell the
cards
they sell the cards if they want to keep
them they keep them it's up to you i
don't really give a [__]
i did it so you guys could and i'm going
to do them every month on patreon i'm
going to run them every [__] month
and i'm going to keep my 25 bucks and if
you guys want to buy them
and sell them for [__] five thousand
dollars
god bless you i'm never gonna knock on
your door and go you're a [__]
scumbag no
you paid attention you backed [__]
joey up
and i'm like [__] uh what's his name
i make money for my partners that's the
way i am that's what i do
i want to make money for you guys i want
to help you the way you [__] help me
so when i did the nft there was some guy
if i don't know what they are
nobody knows what the [__] they are you
want me to sit here and break down
blockchain technology to you and how it
works
uh we don't have the time i do know that
i know a [__] that put
50 000 in a bitcoin account and now he's
getting his dick sucked and he's jumping
up and down and
he's got a chick that just walks around
with him to phantom so
do you have a chick that fans you no do
why no
i think it's time to get in on the
bitcoin because if not i just hire some
chick to stand right here with a bikini
and fan me all day
that's [__] success you know what i'm
saying any idiot can have a [__]
uh tesla look at me i can plug it in my
car
go [__] yourself you want to impress me
show up with a [__]
guy with a rickshaw dead you know what
i'm saying like
i just got here from california i got a
guy with a rickshaw and he's [__]
dying
and his feet are down to the [__]
bone and show up with a chick that
[__] fangirl when i did the longest
shot
adam sandler hired umbrella chicks for
us
[__] you [__] they were all
strippers from albuquerque
we would be on the field they would have
their clothes on and [__] i don't want
you to think it was a [__]
epstein's [__] castle if this was
[__]
they would stand next to you because
they didn't want your son
your face to get a suntan and change
colors throughout the movie
so they had umbrella girls when adam
sandler got me an
umbrella girl who's better than adam
sandler
nobody you understand me that's [__]
style
that's class that's [__] what it's
all about i mean any [__] [__] can
take a private jet
let me see you with some [__] girl
just blowing a [__]
like one of those fans next to you
that's [__] success
take that to the bank [__] it's
monday the 17th of the month
i love you [__] thank you very
much for watching
thank you very much for supporting if
you're on patreon and you got an nfp
i love you [__] i hope you make
money i hope you sell it i hope you
[__] make
your friends tell you're an [__] for
buying it from joey diaz
and you turn around and make fifteen
hundred dollars good for you
i love you [__] we'll be back
wednesday
tip top magoo ready to go on my
back in jersey i could have had a baby
by now it would have been nine months so
it's nine months on wednesday i'm happy
that i left and i'm happy i got to do
the podcast with you guys today and talk
to you [__]
about comedy [__] etiquette your
feelings getting ruined
and uh nfps and all the other [__]
in my life
i love you guys have a great week and
now
for a [__] word for my sponsors
all right thank you very much for
listening today
it was a weird type of podcast but i
enjoy these creepy ones you know what
i'm saying
anyway the joint is brought to you by
blue blocks listen a couple weeks ago i
did a video
with the blue blocks amazing sleep mask
and every night since
i've been sleeping a lot better i
haven't on my sleep apnea machine i have
a little
computer that tells you what amounts
you're sleeping every night it gives you
a summary at the end of the month weekly
the whole thing
ever since i've been using the blue
blocks i've been averaging from 45 to an
hour
a night more sleep and and
i go deeper deep deep deep
i told you about the sleep mask they're
tremendous you get any style color or
size plus
their websites got a virtual website
that you could try on
the glasses but today i'm here to talk
to you about light
filtering glasses first you got the
sleep plus
red lenses for true blue and green light
blocking
you use that after sundown now if you
got trouble sleeping or you get anxious
at night
these are for you then we got the clear
blue light lens filter blue light during
the day
if you spend all day in front of the
computer these are for you the clear
blue light lens
cut down on headaches and eye strain and
finally
they're also hitting you with the summer
glow yellow lenses
color therapy for the winter blues
clinically proven
to lift your mood plus you get all the
benefits of blue light blocking
listen they sent me two pairs of glasses
i love them one for the computer
one to put on at night so i don't get
that much stimulation before i fall
asleep at night
and they're tremendous their lenses are
made under
optic laboratory conditions and if you
got a prescription
there's no problem don't they'll make it
work to your specifications
these lenses are high quality they're
not mass produced
and they come in a ton of styles from
glasses to sleep masks
they got everything you might need for
light therapy
the service is great the customer
service is great
this is a company you want to do
business with so do me a favor go to
blue blocks right now
preston joey when you order and get 20
percent off
with the code use code joey that's
blueblox.com
joey for 20 off blueblocks.com
joey for 20 off the joint is also
brought to you by
cbd lion the best when it comes to cbd
how do i know
because they [__] got me out of this
rut with this knee surgery that's how i
know
it reduced the pain it reduced the
swelling
i mean the gummies are great the cbd
flower is great the bat balls are great
the roll-on
if you need cbd this is the way to go do
me a favor go to the cbd line right now
read the third-party lab results read
the results
if you have an ailment they'll tell you
what cbd
and the dosage and everything to use
this company is tremendous again
another great website cbd lion
preston joey joint and get 20
off delivered to the house preston i
don't give a [__] what you're pressing
they're a good company they know i sent
you just tell them i sent you
and they'll take care you're right
cbdlion.com
use coach joint or church whatever the
[__] it is
and you get 20 off your order i want to
thank blue blocks
i want to thank cbd lion but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__]
for being [__] savages and for
supporting the church of the church
to join i'm getting confused myself now
i love you guys have a great week
and i'll see you guys tip top magoo
wednesday morning
i love you stay black have a great week
foreign
[Music]
you